-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-I appreciate that.
I appreciate you being
in a good mood.
It was a difficult week,
a very depressing week.
I'm sure you saw Hamas,
the terrorist group
that runs Ga-- Gaza, um...
broke into Israel,
killed over 1,300 people,
men, women and children.
And then the college kids
in America... (CHUCKLES)
...went full Trump and said,
"There's very fine people
on both sides."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
What is going on?
Thirty-four, uh,
Harvard stu-- uh, associations--
student associations
signed a letter that basically
threw their lot in
with the killers.
Uh, but there was a backlash
because some CEO said,
"When these kids
now go for a job,
they're going
to be blacklisted."
-And...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
And a lot of the students
are still standing
by their position
to support the war criminals,
but they strenuously object
to the word, "blacklist."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Wow.
(CHUCKLES)
Amazing.
Even Kanye said,
"That is some anti-Semitic
bullshit, right there."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Uh... (CLEARS THROAT)
(AUDIENCE CONTINUES APPLAUDING)
And then there's
the Democratic Socialists
of America.
I didn't really--
wasn't aware of these people,
but, uh, they exist
and I'm not sure I'm with them.
Uh, the Connecticut Chapter, uh,
put out a statement,
they said,
"No peace on stolen land."
Uh, this is from Connecticut.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
An-- (CHUCKLES)
An Indian word that means,
"That land you stole."
-So, you know...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And by the way,
it's not stolen land.
Okay? Not stolen land.
Uh... (CHUCKLES)
So, yes, and then I heard
about this other person
I was not aware of before.
Pornstar, Mia Khalifa, uh,
also rejoiced in the killing.
Uh, she said that they should
turn their phones horizontal
so she could see the carnage
in 4K,
proving that you literally
can have your brain fucked out.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING)
Uh...
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Man... (CHUCKLES)
Where is Donald Trump
when you need someone
to pay a pornstar
to shut the fuck up?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
Yes, I'm-- I'm learning
about Mia Khalifa.
She apparently is famous
for giving a blowjob in a hijab.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I'm not kidding.
Really did that. I-- I wonder
if you know this, Mia,
that if you tried to practice
your trade in Gaza,
I'm not sure they would give you
a warm welcome.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Uh...
No, they would because you'd be
on fire, you nitwit.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Ha-- (CHUCKLES)
But of course, now everyone
in Israel is asking,
"How did this devastating breach
of security even happen?
Why did Israeli intelligence
not get an idea
that this was coming?
Why did American intelligence
not know this?"
And Marjorie Taylor Greene said,
"Where were the space lasers?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)